soyez les bienvenus à l'indigobe
est incroyable
[Musique]
je passe vraiment de super vacances
tout à l'heure
tu savais que ce soir c'était ma
dernière soirée
je me suis dit qu'on pourrait peut-être
faire un truc spécial
maman
je suis sûr qu'elle va très bien
de nombreux témoins ont vu Alison au bar
hier soir
avec deux jeunes hommes de l'île
mais que ce soit bien clair
la police a conclu que la mort d'Alison
Thomas
était accidentel la mort de notre fille
n'est pas accident tout le monde le sait
tu sais ce qui est cool avec les
vacances c'est que personne ne connaît
c'est l'occasion de rencontrer des gens
différents
le meurtre de ma sœur a fait les gros
titres pendant un an
parfois je me dis que
tout le monde c'est plus que moi sur ce
qu'il est vraiment arrivé tu as besoin
de te faire aider parce que ce que tu
fais ça s'appelle du harcèlement
ma sœur
qui importe
la police me recherche ok donc quand il
demande pour la fille on l'a plus jamais
revu c'est clair je dois avouer que je
passe vraiment de super moment avec vous
je dois aller jusqu'au
bout pour elle